When I was 17, I was diving
off the coast of South Florida
and I saw the most beautiful
fish I had ever seen.
It had these bold stripes
and these big dramatic spines.
And I had no idea
what it was.
So I went to the
dive master and he told me
I had just seen a lionfish.
And I was hooked.
I started reading
everything I could
about this strange
and beautiful fish
and what I found
completely astounded me.
I had no idea that
something so gorgeous
could be causing such harm on
our native reef ecosystems.
Lionfish are what is known
as an invasive species.
And that's defined as a species
that is non-native to its area
and that is causing harm
or is likely to cause harm.
Now, lionfish are originally
from the Indo-Pacific region
and they were introduced off
the coast of South Florida
in the mid 1980s.
And most likely it was
through an aquarium release.
So, someone who
had some pet lionfish
didn't want to take
care of them anymore
and then just dumped them
into the local waterways.
So this is problematic
for a couple of reasons.
First, lionfish are
prolific breeders.
They can produce two million
eggs over the course of one year
and one lion fish and
all of her offspring
can produce 8.1 quintillion eggs
in just three months.
And the other thing is they
are voracious predators.
They're essentially like the
hoover vacuums of the sea.
They can eat anything
up to half their size
and unfortunately that includes
a lot of the really cool
interesting reef fish
that we like to see on
the reef as divers.
To top it all off they have
a series of venomous
spines lining their back.
This produces a very
nasty neurotoxin
that causes pain and
swelling if you're stung.
One of my interviewees
told me that it won't kill you
but it will make you
wish you were dead.
So, this is
definitely not a fish
that we want wandering around
where it doesn't belong.
And the more I read
about this fish
the more I realized that there
was a lot of talk about
the biology and
ecology of lionfish.
But really was--
no one was diving into
the kind of social
implications of this fish.
So, I went to South Florida and
I found this
incredible community that has
completely rallied around
the removal of this species
using whatever resources
they have at their disposal.
For example, you have
Bob and Maria Hickerson.
They're located
in South Florida
and they would go in their
free time, and try and remove
as many lionfish as possible
on their local reefs.
But they were getting
so frustrated because
they were leaving so
many fish behind.
So, they took some tools and
random things they found
at Home Depot
and created the very first
lionfish-specific spear gun.
So, now you can remove them
at a much faster rate.
And then, Maria takes
the spines and the fins
and creates really beautiful
pieces of lionfish jewelry.
She then sells them to support
the removal initiatives
but also raise awareness about
lionfish as an invasive species.
So, the great thing
about lionfish is that
they're actually delicious to
eat, and that's something that
John Mirabella,
who lives in Marathon Key
found out for himself.
He would go out and remove
lionfish in the morning
and take it back to the
restaurant he owned on Marathon
and just experiment with all
different types of recipes.
So, here's lionfish sushi
which I tried and
it was delicious.
And then I did run
out of food money.
I spent it all on diving.
I have my priorities
really messed up.
And so, I ended up eating
lionfish for almost every meal
for like two weeks...
( laughs )
which was totally barbaric.
But it was delicious.
And the great thing is
that in John's restaurant
he marketed that he
was serving lionfish
in the local newspapers
and people were coming
from all over the Keys
to sample this fish
which shows that even if people
are removing them themselves
they're excited to support
initiatives that are.